it's great to be joined today by Dr
Shira doron who's the chief infection
control officer for Tufts medicine
health system and also the hospital
epidemiologist at Tufts Medical Center
in Boston really great having you on
today I appreciate your time
great to be with you so I've been
reading all of these analyzes and
meta-analyzes and meta meta-analyzes of
what might be thought of as a simple
question do masks work to prevent covid
and it seems as though even the most
well-intentioned and sort of
science-facing people have had a
different and sometimes changing
perspectives on this question throughout
the pandemic there's also sort of a
question of
what do we mean by do they work and that
might mean what is the effect for an
individual of their decision to wear a
mask versus what is a policy of saying
we require masking in these those or
other situations what does that do on
the population level infection rate so
start wherever you want on this question
and and then we can kind of go from
there where are you maybe now on this
issue yeah I mean I think you hit the
nail on the head right this is not a
simple question do masks work
um and you know where I am now is is in
many ways where I started before the
pandemic was even a you know a glimmer
in our eye which is that I've quite
literally trusted masks with my life
um I my whole career I have obviously
worn masks in healthcare I'm not a
surgeon so I've worn masks for my own
protection and I believe in them I I
have taken care of patients with deadly
bacterial meningitis in an ear loop
surgical mask I have taken care of
patients with
um H1N1 influenza before there was a
vaccine for it in a surgical mask
um and I've taken care of patients with
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis in an
n95 and I have trusted it to protect me
and keep me healthy and alive and I
still do to this day
um but when the pandemic was bearing
down on us
um SARS Covey too the kova 19 pandemic
um I started to have to really look at
all of that literature because questions
started to arise that were really quite
um contentious you know the first
question was should we be using surgical
masks or n95 to take care of these
suspected kova 19 patients that was a
really difficult one because we didn't
have nearly enough n95s available in
this country to take care of every
person with a respiratory infection in
the winter in an n95 and so we really
needed to start looking at the data
which suggested that it wasn't clear-cut
whether you needed an n95 in that
situation and the CDC was really kind of
hedging on its language who was being
very clear that you did not meet an n95
um and so you may have seen that there
was relatively recently a clinical trial
that assessed n95s versus surgical masks
they started back in those days when we
really didn't know what to do and didn't
have enough n95s and actually found that
they couldn't detect a difference in
healthcare worker infection rates
between those hospitals who used n95 for
all Cova care and those who used
surgical masks
um
that's not to say that the n95s aren't
more protective many of those healthcare
workers got those infections outside of
health care right and that seems to be a
lot of the difficulty where if we just
say as sensible people the tighter the
barrier that we place between ourselves
and a pathogen seems pretty logical that
it reduces the chance of that pathogen
getting through great okay so we can
start there but then you go to all sorts
of different studies and you have to
contend with questions like just because
you have a mandate doesn't mean
everyone's doing it just because people
are doing it part of the day doesn't
mean they're doing it all of the day
just because you are ostensibly wearing
an n95 Mask doesn't mean you're wearing
it correctly or you don't have it pulled
down or pulled up or you know on your
sleeve or so so are those some of the
difficulties in getting to what is the
TR the quote true answer
that's really why the question is it is
more than do masks work it's do mask
mandates work or does masking on a
community level result in a lower
level of infection transmission or
number of infections
um than not masking on a community level
and what are you comparing it to no
masks at all optional masking versus
mandated masking you know all of those
things are those all of those
comparisons are different comparisons
yeah um and we have data that show that
those broader sort of community level
interventions are are quite a bit less
effective
um than you would want them to be given
that we do believe all the week is
really hard to show with science that
masks are protecting us when we wear
them and some of the data evidence for
that was also quite early on
um in healthcare
in you know looking specifically at SARS
Kobe 2 what we were seeing was that
healthcare workers did not have higher
rates of SARS Pro V2 antibody positivity
people who weren't healthcare workers
even though we were surrounded by
covid-19 patients all day long and that
was telling me that our PPE was working
there's sort of a parallel
um maybe we would call it an issue here
that is separate from a mask mandate
which maybe we can also introduce which
is I've read a couple of studies which
suggests that
when news media is accurately informing
people about the prevalence of a virus
meaning people are aware of when risk is
higher versus when when risk is lower
that people choose to behave differently
not only in terms of optional Mass
wearing in places like grocery stores
but also in terms of how social am I
going to be am I going to go to sporting
events Etc so this would be the idea
that it's less about mandating one thing
or another
but that if people perceive oh there's a
new variant like for example after
Thanksgiving of whichever year it was
when Delta first came or whichever one
it was when people perceive the risk is
higher they will modify their behavior
and that this is a way that we actually
do flatten the curve over a period of a
couple of months and so it's less about
mandating but more about informing and
that many people will actually make the
choice that is logical anyway is that
something that needs to be considered
when the effectiveness is measured
yeah that's exactly right so you know
this gets to one of the CDC studies
um that you know was really instrumental
in the development of their
recommendations during the Omicron wave
to shift to the highest quality Mass you
can wear instead of cloth masks
um unless that's the highest quality
mask you can uh tolerate
um so the recommendation was and 95s are
the most protective k95s are the second
most protective surgical masks and then
cloth masks and that was based on this
paper that they put out in their mmwr
report showing that people who
um used n95s
um so so people who tested positive
versus negative for SARS Kobe 2
infection covet infection
um where uh were more likely to be
negative if they had used a higher
quality mask essentially was the result
of that study
um and the critique to that is people
who wear n95 are more likely to be
coveted cautious in general right
because those were not that was not a
randomized controlled clinical trial and
the this is the critique for any
observational study any epidemiologic
study any study where you compare to two
geographical locations for example
um so there's a new study that shows
that um you know States and counties
with mass minutes had lower infection in
the United States but not lower death
rates for example some of those things
are exactly what you're saying if you
don't randomize in a randomized control
chemical trial and you just observe the
people who choose to wear the the higher
quality mask people who choose to wear
masks over no masks are also taking
covid more seriously and doing those
other things the states and counties
that choose to issue mandates are also
issuing mandates related to other things
they may have more business closures
they may have more people in them that
take covet seriously right that's why
the conference and systematic review old
and new and really any kind they do a
systematic review on anything masks and
treatments
um
in in medicine will always focus on
randomized controlled clinical trials
because that's the only way to take all
those other factors out of the
calculation if we want to in sort of one
sentence give what might be the most
comprehensive but also accurate
assessment is it fair to say that a
correctly worn high quality mask does a
good job of protecting the individual
wearing it but mask mandates are less
effective at protecting a population for
all of the different reasons that you've
cited so far like is that kind of where
we land
that's what I believe to be true I can't
say that we have great data to prove
that you're wearing an n95 is definitely
going to protect you from cobit 19. but
that's what my three plus years of
experience in a hospital being based in
kova 19 tell me plus the what I you know
what I refer to as the zero prevalence
data for healthcare workers Etc the low
rate of transmission that I see on a
day-to-day basis and it's my job to see
that between patients and staff so I
believe that a high quality well-fitting
mask will protect me if I wear one but I
agree um with the second part of what
you said which is that I have been
unable to see convincing evidence that a
mask mandate or that Community masking
makes any difference in the incidence of
infection and the data that we have from
78 clinical trials suggests that if
there is a difference there it's very
very small the epidemiologic data of
comparing County to County and state to
state and Country to Country based on
mass use suggests that if there's any
difference there at all it's very very
small and that should really call into
question the the discussion around
future mandates in my opinion even
though as I said I've been trusting
masks with my life
there are all sorts of claims that we've
seen over the last few years about the
harms of masks sometimes these are what
people call psychological harms related
to kids in schools or being able to
communicate or whatever the case may be
you then have the stuff like well it
forces you to re-breathe your own carbon
dioxide and all of these different
things and they've took to my relative
satisfaction mostly been all debunked
with the exception of it does seem that
for little babies
exposure to an overwhelming number of
people where they don't see their mouth
when they are being spoken to May delay
language development to some degree and
it seems to be temporary I mean I know
I'm bringing a lot of new new things in
here but on the criticisms of The Masks
what do we actually know at this point
yeah I mean if we go back to when we
first started to think about Community
level masking which was in healthcare so
it's March of 2020 uh more and more of
our health care workers are getting
infected generally at home and in the
community not through care of patients
with covet because they're wearing masks
with patients
um and we are uh and they're getting
exposed and we're having to furlough
them for two weeks we immediate it five
minutes after we started to do that we
realized we can't run a hospital with
the number of people that are home
waiting to you know usually not contract
covet after an exposure we start
bringing them back and we have them
where those who are exposed to covert we
have them wear masks so you know very
quickly half of our health care
Workforce was wearing masks but we
didn't have a mask mandate in health
care yet because
masks had been shown in several
meta-analyzes not to be effective for
that purpose and that's why we had
avoided doing that but as I watched
people wearing masks because of exposure
I saw a lot of people touching them you
know touching them people putting them
down on the table to eat on a surface
that somebody else was going to eat on I
saw a lot of things that made me really
nervous about the even the having the
conversation around bringing masks in as
a long-term strategy as a mandate for
healthcare workers
um
but we did it we did it because you know
it got to the point where everyone was
exposed
um and we needed to protect each other
um and then as you know it became a
standard um and recommended by the CDC
for the whole country
um you know the data on its
Effectiveness hadn't changed
um the data on community masking hadn't
changed between the CDC not recommending
Community masking and recommending
Community masking but the stakes were so
High
um people were dying and the hospitals
were filling up and people were going to
be dying of non-coveted reasons because
they couldn't get a bed in the hospital
and it was worth it it was worth it to
try and I I have to admit I didn't have
the creativity to think how we could
possibly Implement Community masking on
a national level given the supply chain
issues um I didn't think that people
could make them at home and I lacked
that creativity and I was wrong we did
it and we did it effective
um but then what I started to see over
time you know especially as the children
in schools uh were wearing masks was
um
but also here in the hospital working
every day throughout the whole pandemic
was a loss of connection
um when you couldn't see people's
expressions in people's faces you were
just much less likely to you know have
those kind of intimate conversations
um we were able to drop masks in the
hospital in areas where patients and
um and the public were restricted from
entering so after everyone was
vaccinated in the summer of 2021 we
stopped wearing masks in offices and
conference rooms and break rooms and it
was night and day in terms of morale
combating burnout and what we had just
been through
um and then we had to put the mask back
on because the Delta variant was immune
invasive and people were vaccinated
people were getting infected again and
it was hard
um so I think that sure there are there
are there are definite downsides when it
comes to people who are hearing impaired
not being able to tell what's going on
people who are trying to learn language
people you know with speech impairments
um
you know and and you know children who
have the developmental uh delays and and
that sort of social interaction piece
um but I I really did see amongst my my
children and my friends children and
amongst my colleagues just an impact on
connection uh mood morale that has
really improved again when we were able
to take masks off about a year ago and
and last thing the rebreathing of your
own carbon dioxide does not seem to be a
problem no no I wasn't sorry about that
at all and again you know and we do know
that our that our surgeons wear masks
for 16 hour cases and you know there's
there's no issue so that would not be
one of my concerns now n95s
um you know OSHA does require that
someone that that workers be medically
clear to wear n95 respirators uh those
will cause shortness of breath that can
cause you know cardiovascular issues
when you wear them for prolonged periods
of time and of course we've all seen the
pictures of the you know skin breakdown
that you can have if you have to wear
them for prolonged periods of time
during a period where everybody has
coveted or suspected covid which was the
case in Spring of 2020. um so those can
can have some health implications all
right we've been speaking with Dr Shira
Duron from Tufts Medical Center in
Boston and also Chief infection control
officer for Tufts medicine Health System
really appreciate your time and your
insights today
it was such a pleasure